the first selection in the 1997 National Hockey
League entry draft belongs to the Boston Bruins
the Bruins picking first overall for the
first time since 1982 and Joel thoron of
the Seuss St Marie Greyhound sits anxiously with
his parents way and Mary waiting for his name to
be called the Boston Bruins select as number
one pick in the 1997 draft Joe [Music] thoron
Aon dropping it back th moving in for shot to
th first in the National Hockey League Thon
head up Z up had a stick [__] ready to go one
time to her he had no shot McLaren for one time
her save flon stop SC the Murray in front back
to save scores three on one Murray for th for
Cano scores tick tck oh man Rush th hold it in
front score a tremendous feed by th his fourth
assist on the night sets up that OG winning
good shot score Canal there's the 100th point
for thoron Joe thoron 101 points this season well
it's just a fantastic year Joe thoron has been
dominant arguably the best player in the NHL
when he's on top of his game Thon in on goal
Thon score he now leaves the National Hockey
League in points Jo thoron with a marvelous
the San Jose Sharks arguably have just made the
biggest trade in their history Joe thoron from
the Boston Bruins comes to the Sharks a guy who's
in the prime of his career Joe thoron a superstar
super Joe Jumbo Joe he's the real deal he's a
legit dominant forward right now top players
in the world he's big and strong and physical
and he's hard to contain Patrick hared over
to Thon with ended this game and sent everyone
to the exit Thorton tied with yarma yogger for
the NHL scoring League and you are now looking at
the NHL scoring leader Joe Thorton has become the
first player in 76 years to record more assists
than the previous season's scoring leader had
points and the winner is Joe thoron here's Thon
Marlo scores Patrick Marlo wins it here and he
scor it's a four on one back the other way shot
and stop rebound score Joe Thon has played over
1500 regular season in playoff games Joe Thorton's
first Stanley Cup Final appearance in his 19 years
syney craby he'll face off against Joe Thor
18 years in the National Hockey League lots
of great stats but always the dream and now he
and his team get their first Stanley Cup Final
and the Pittsburgh Penguins have won the Stanley
[Applause] Cup but the chant of the home crowd is
is for their team they are proud it's a very hard
trophy to win you know ultimately you got to beat
four teams there's so many things that have to go
right I've been lucky to play against some pretty
incredible players over my career but I think the
guy that stands at the top of that list has to be
Jumbo Joe great vision by Joe shoot it TI score
Joe Thon there's number 1,000 now he's wandering
back toward the line in front to Marlo he scores
are you kidding me with that pass right on to the
tape of Marlo bam boom what a by just a great
passer and great player he is and he helped me
out so much in my game alone so I I owe a lot to
him he just loves the game he loves his teammates
and his teammates really appreciate him he's been
a special player for two decades I still believe
that he's underrated still don't think he gets the
credit he deserves the playmaker of his generation
has his 1,000 NHL assist his first nhn hattick
in eight years Thon Dy score Joe thoron has 1500
career points amazing player you know one of the
best F probably all time in hockey complete Game
physically defensively offensively every element
of the game you would look for from a player Joe
thoron is one of the alltime greats I love them
everybody loves jumbo Dr I've been privileged to
play this game for a long time so I don't take
anything for granted I never think what ifs to
be honest with me I just kind of try to live
in the moment and go from there the seemingly
Carefree attitude you have towards things how much
does that help you as a hockey player yeah I just
go and just uh don't worry about a thing just go
and play my game and hopefully uh things go well